parce que j'en ai un qui arrive là j'en
ai une autre sur les genoux une rustine
dans le coeur battre par kosma pascal et
à qui vous avez pas fait d'études alors
j'ai préparé un petit tour oui voyez on
a quelqu'un l'a alors vous serez associé
de l'a4 que vous voulez il y avait
trouvé la 4c chaque fois vous vous
glissez pour un cours de ce quart temps
voit maintenant que ça va mais vite
écoutez partie de soirée soit belle
apprenez parce qu'ils n'ont jamais rien
après mais vite non pas sur la voie
ferrée garde qui avait trouvé là quatre
gardes rustines on pouvait pas expliquer
pourquoi ses oreilles noires et bien
c'est la carte que vous avez choisi
c'est les deux de coeur va bien sûr vous
ne les connaissez tout par coeur le
patron commençaient l'aide des corps qui
manque si vous accélérez mal à me serais
bien c'est pas pour ça que je suis venu
parce que c'est trop cher jamais tourné
aussi je trouve quelque chose de cool
l'a406 et les deux des cas et vous voyez
qu'il l'a cédé 4 oui oui il s'agit là
c'est le dos ici c'est le cas alors vous
avez bien regardé parce que 24 ans mais
ceux-ci climat mais on va essayer qui se
retourne tout se regarde comme ça
souffle plus fort
plus fort que ça fait trois fois que je
souffre
oui et voilà le décor et chalets tout
comme les décors que vous l'avez soit si
ça allait tourner tout son nom ça c'est
pas mal du tout sur le feu enfin ça fait
bref ne touchent pas toujours pas
commencé à marcher vous m'expliquer en
quoi tout à l'heure battez vous voulez
bien aviation je m'en vais là on verra
merci garcimore au revoir à bientôt pour
ou en étage
[Musique]